I've always been an adventurer I've
always kind of pushed the boundaries and
looked for experiences that most people
don't know exist and this is one that I
had come across many years ago and I
wanted to make happen but descending
into a Y volcano where the the love of
farting poisonous gas I mean you know
it's an amazing thing yeah it was
certainly unlike anything else that I've
ever done was a hot pot at the top
extremely hot at the bottom it was about
a thousand degrees Fahrenheit radiant
when you're approaching the shore of the
lava lake so yes and you know it's
interesting to me in you know in a world
of GoPro where they think the you know
these adventures sort of some become
real to people what the business
opportunity is they're both from a media
standpoint and then beyond yeah
absolutely I mean I think there's so
many opportunities to capture incredible
content with cameras like that so that
was part of my intent is especially in
this most recent expedition going down
there with the film crew and actually
capturing it in a way like it's never
been seen before and what kind of tech
was involved so I partnered with two
companies actually one was a drone
company called DJI and the other one was
a wearable tech company that makes a
product that measures your emotional
response to a given experience and you
can imagine that was kind of all over
the map but it it's a freak out across
your chest what is the emotional one
gets us there lowered into a volcano
yeah well it was it was all over the map
you know there were peaks of excitement
and troughs of nervousness and stress we
were able to actually take that data
overlay it on to the GoPro footage that
I had and kind of retrace exactly what I
was feeling and come back with a story
to tell that's more than just imagery
actually really so you use the data to
add to the native narrative and then
narrate it on top of that that's exactly
right so I'm super passionate about
experiences I'm also equally passionate
about technology and in this kind of
digital millennial age I think there's a
cool opportunity to merge those world so
that's exactly what we did what are you
passionate about experiences passionate
about unearthing you know experiences
and adventures and activities that are
unknown or lesser-known and reporting
back to the world on things that most
people don't know exist
I don't know a lot about do you feel
like the the reporting of it itself
somehow takes away from the personal
experience or is or do you push yourself
further because you know everyone's
gonna see it that's a good question I
think there's an element to technology
it allows me to capture the experience
in a way without detracting from it
personally which is part of the reason
why I thought it would be interesting to
record this I don't have to talk into a
microphone I'm just descending and my
body is doing what it's doing and we're
able to kind of visualize that in the
form of graphs pie charts and a
biometric thumbprint actually which we
created fascinating you know so what's
the revenue model here how do you get
the payback so far side of the thrill
yeah outside of the thrill I've not
actually monetized this yet but my goal
moving forward is to to create a whole
series of adventures and embark with
technology and sponsor these experiences
from companies that are looking for
branding opportunities and tell a story
tell a story on digital outlets and on
television
GoPro thinks if they're gonna build a
media business if they're somehow gonna
get people don't know give them the
videos or they'll own the media yeah
they've got a channel on Virgin America
Airlines and they've got little things
on YouTube there were some big things on
YouTube what do you think of the
company's intention to own that kind of
media you know I think it's it's a
brilliant model they have a distributed
team of filmmakers from all around the
world that are probably pretty stoked to
just submit their films but for in my
case I'm particularly interested in
actually owning that content and working
with lots of different partners so not
necessarily handing that over for free
per se but certainly partnering with a
lot of companies including GoPro and I
think there's a lot of natural synergies
there